はい 最後になりますが
まあ経験を生かすということ
先に忘れる一番大切な原因
人間っていうのはもうよく行動したり
喋ったり 計画立てたり
何でもかんでもするんだけど
一番真っ先に忘れてしまうんですね
経験という一言 経験って何ですかね
まあ能力ということですね
難しくないね ね 技術的
知識的経験もあるが 仏教は性格的な経験は優先順位の大事にするんです
それで覚えておいて 経験は三種類なんです
技術的経験 体を動かして習うもの
それから知識 学んでいる経験
三番目 何ですか？性格的な経験
本当はその三番目は一番トップなんです
これから説明します 技術的
知識的経験があっても
性格的な問題で無駄になったり
逆効果になったり 曲がったりします
自分には技術的な経験はありますけど
性格が悪い 何するかわからないんですよ
例えばもう学校で理科系でビシビシといろんな学んで経験は持ったところで
それで爆弾を組み立てたりとかね
携帯で爆弾を爆破する方法とか
そんなことを考えちゃう
どうしますかね 実際にそういうことをやっている人々はいますから
だから学んだものはもう逆効果になって
学ばなかった方が良かったのではないかということになります
ということで 知識も技術も役に立たなくなりますよ
性格が悪ければ そこで仏教の世界はどちらかというと
この性格の経験を教える世界なんです
技術は教えません しかし
知識もそれなりには教える
それも俗世間の知識ではなくて
知識 正しい知識は何なのかということと
知識を得る方法というところですね
性格が悪い場合は 技術
知識を断った物語もあります
それはブッダの物語なんです
ジャータカ物語 そういう物語あるんですよ
まあ一応すごい小さく
まあ短い時間で紹介しますけど
えーと 菩薩があるバーラナシ国である日は音楽家の家庭で生まれて
ヴィーナのヴィーナとバイオリンでしょうかね
弦楽器ですね 弦楽器のプロになったんです
そこでも天才的な能力を持っている
天才なんです それで王様のところで仕事をしているんです
だから給料も結構よろしいし
兼ねるいい立場でいるんです
そこでバーラナシの商人たちが
商売で別な国に行くんです
その国に行ったら もうもうすぐさっさと商売はうまくいって
金もたくさん儲かっちゃって
もうそろそろ自分の国へ帰らなくちゃいけないんですね
それでまあ一つ まあどんな昔も今も同じですから
まあ相談成立したところで
まあ一つちょっとどこかで飲み屋さんでご飯食べて
みんなで楽しくお祝いするでしょう
そういうことで この商人たちはいっぱいごちそう
そういう店に行って ごちそうを用意してもらって
ご飯食べて楽しくわいわいとやってます
そうすると まあせっかくだからね
まあ今ならカラオケでよかったのにね
まあカラオケなかったんで
当時に それであの音楽でも聞こうかなと
言ったらもう金持ちだからね
この国で一番トップの音楽家は誰ですか？と
呼びなさいと 今すごい態度でかいんです
お金はいくらでもありますからね
言うとものすごい有名な人がいて
もうもうあの人には誰もかなわないんだよという人がいて
あ 呼びます 呼んだんですよ
呼んで この人は酒飲みながらご飯食べながら
もうあの人は一生懸命弦楽器を演奏しているんです
誰も聞こうとしないんですね
なんか日本の高級レストランと同じみたいです
誰も聞こうとしない その代わりギャーギャーしゃべったりして
それでこの人はプロだから
やっぱりプロの有名な人を呼ぶ場合は
いくらホテルでもね やっぱりその場合はみんなその演奏をメインにしてディナーパーティーに行くでしょ
ディナーショーなんかの場合は
食べることは食べるんだけど
やっぱり有名な人の演奏の方がやっぱりメインなんです
だからこの人はもう自分がね
せっかくこういうことで呼ばれて
演奏ぐらいちょこっと聞いてもいいじゃないかと
もうこの連中はね 金があるんだけど
大馬鹿者ではないかと
音楽なんかは知りもしないみたいだと
ただ金の力を見せるために私を呼んだのではないかと言って
プロとしてパイプを消し込んじゃったんです
プロは金に負けませんだから
言ったら聞くんです あんた方は私を呼んでなんで音楽を聞かないのかと
もしかするとあんた方
音楽というのを聞いたこと何もないでしょうと
音楽ってどんなものかと
ちょっと一人の人は あのね
先生 我々も待っているんだよと
演奏は 首を長くして なんか先生楽器を調整してるとか思ってたんだよ
あれ 演奏でしたかと 楽器の調整にはやけに時間かかると思ってたんだ
と言ったら ものすごく怒って何言うのかと
言ったら言い返したんですね
我々ぶつくさと音楽を知らないと
あんだらかんだらとかね
我々のバールなしに国でこういう先生がいるんだよと
我々はしょっちゅうその先生の演奏を聴いているんだよと
それに比較してしまったと申し訳ないんだと
あなたはただの楽器の調整ぐらいで
それうまくまだできてないでしょうと言われた途端
もうこの人もやっぱり音楽家だから
そういうことかと すぐ自分の国の仕事をやめて
私をどうか連れて行ってください
言って出ていくんです
その場で そういうところ
現在のインドと違いますよ
すぐカッパする時ってすぐ決めたことをやる
辞めた仕事は その人はその国の王様のところで仕事していたんです
辞めて あの長い道をね
あの歩いて行かなくちゃいけないし
まあ一応車っていうかね
牛車 馬車ですからね 行って
あの先生のところに行く
菩薩のところに行ったら
この菩薩のお母さんがいるんですね
お母さんは見えないんです
菩薩は王様の音楽家で仕事してますけど
お母さんの面では全部自分の手でやる
体洗ってあげて 服を全部綺麗に洗っておいて
それからご飯作って食べさせて
まあまた午後ですから
帰るのはその間に 昼食べるものとか
全部朝早く作って置いておいて出ているのです
で それであの人がこの家を訪ねて家に行くんですけど
先生はいないんです 先生は仕事に行ってるんだからね
見たら誰もいない 家は空いてるし
本人が何のことなく家に入ったんですね
入ってじーっと待っていると
まあ楽器 音楽家の家だからね
またヴィーナー一つ見たんですね
見たら まあじゃあちょこっと何か演奏でもしようかなと思って
ヴィーナーを取って弾き始めたんです
そこで目が見えないお母さんがいきなり床を叩きながらシュッシュッと言うんですね
すごくなんか心配しちゃって
言ったら この若者はなんでそんなシュッシュッシュと言うんでしょうか？と言ったら
いやいや うちの息子のね
せがれのはあれ食べてる
あれで食べてるんだから
あれネズミが噛んでいるんだと
お母さん それ困るでしょうね
自分 自分の息子がね まああの楽器で食べているんだからね
これがネズミが噛んじゃうと
それでプライドは粉々に壊れちゃったんです
あの人の 目が見えないお母さんから見れば
もうネズミが噛んでいるんですね
弦を それで その人はお母さんのところで土下座して
実はネズミを噛んでいるんじゃないんだと
私も音楽を学びたくて
長い道をね すごい日にちをかけて参りましたと
先生は今どこにいるんでしょうかと言ったら
あいつはもう午後になると来るでしょう
お前は待ちなさいと言ってお母さんに言われて
で 待っていて 待っていたら若者が家にいると
お前誰かと聞いたら 私はこういうことで隣の国から来たんだと
言った途端断る 出て行きなさい
あなたにはちょっとでも教えてあげませんよと厳密に断るの
出て行け 出て行け いくら頑張ってももう聞かない
で なんで菩薩は断ったかというと
人相を見たんですね 見たら性格が悪い
裏切り者 恩知らない性格
そういう人には学問は与えるんじゃないんだという菩薩の立場なんです
悪結果になりますから
で ずっと断る断る 本人はまあ遠くから来たんだから
家に住んでいるのには反対はないし
ご飯を食べるのもそれは別にどうということはないんですけど
教えることだけ 弟子入りだけは断る
で この人はもう若者が決めて
ずっと家でも頑固で止めて泊まって
で 先生は出て行くんだから
お母さんの面倒は次から次へ全部見るんです
ずっと そうやっていると
まあお母さんは女だからね
一生懸命自分の面倒を見ていると
やっぱりもうかわいそうやと思っちゃうしね
まあ息子はもうほとんど午前中は日中はいないし
不安でしょうし それでも何でもやってくれるし
言ったらまあ息子に言うんじゃ
お前はね なんでそんな頑固なのかと
そんな性格の悪い子を育てた覚えはないんだよとか
菩薩に言うんです あの若者は必死でしょうと
教えてあげたらもう何が悪いんでしょうかと
教えてあげなさいよというと
菩薩はいくら悪人であろうとも
まあこれはしょうがないと
親には逆らうべきじゃないんだと
いうことで まあ一応弟子入りしたんですけど
後から大変なことになったんです
それで一人でそこでストップします
あとで菩薩はもう大変なことになったんです
でも菩薩だから いくら大変なことがあったって乗り越えて勝ちますからね
仏教はいつでも勝利者の教えだからね
負けたストーリーは一つもないんです
大変なことっていうのは
この人はやっぱりものすごい真剣に学んだんです
菩薩も教える場合はもう隠すことなく全部教えるんだと全部教えたんです
教えて学問終わったところで
まあそんな程度やと ということで
では君をもう卒業させなくちゃあかんだからね
というわけで じゃあ王様にこうした国
バラナシ国の一番大きい国のね
王様に面会させますと
いうことで会わせて まあそれで王様がよかったよかったと反抗してくれば
どこでも仕事できるでしょう
連れて行ったんですね
言ったら ああ お前の弟子かということで
王様も親切で では一つ演奏してみてくださいと
そしたら演奏したんですね
もう全くもうレベルがもう上がって
先生と同じなんですね
そこでソロをやっても素晴らしいし
では先生と対話的な一つやりなさいと言ったら
それまたすごい 先生から学んだものだから
インドのこの二人で音楽をやる
今でも同じ文化ありますけどね
まあ楽譜ないんです 楽譜なく
この気持ちでやるんです
だからそれはなかなか先生と弟子でなきゃなかなかできないんですよ
あるいはものすごい心通じている仲間で
楽譜だったら楽譜見ながらやればいいんだけどね
ということは いつでも即興で
その場でその場でいろんなものを作っちゃうんです
だからかなり能力なきゃできませんよ
だから揃って演奏する人々は間違っちゃうと
これで大変なことになります
あのインドの一番有名な亡くなったラビンドラナート・ラージャ
じゃなくて このラビシャンカールっていうね
シタリストいて まあ西洋でもどこでも
まあもう天才みたいな能力でね
すぐその場で演奏して見せるんですよ
しかし その打楽器が必要なんですね
このそれはどこへ行っても
ある一人の人しか連れて行かないんです
その人もその打楽器のもうインドの一流のプロで
この二人はいつでも組んでいるんです
だから ラビシャンカールがいきなり気分が変わって
なんか全く違う演奏を始めちゃうと
あの人は何のことなくそれに合わせて
だからお互い心を読むというね
これ大変な技術で それで二つやったところで
まあ先生とうまくあって
王様が喜んじゃって ああ
こんなもうなかなか珍しいと
このさ グッティラって名前ですけど
名前グッティラね 合わせる人っていうのはいないわけ
いるわけじゃないんだと驚いちゃって
自分であの雇うことにしちゃったんです
じゃあ君 今日から私は雇いますからね
先生の給料の半分あげますと
これも結構給料ですけど
で  OK になって出て行って
この人は給料半分ということで気が入
気に入らないんですね
一人で悶々と 先生の能力も私の同じでしょうと
なんで給料半分でしょうか
そこである意味 そこからこの性格が悪いってことで
先生というのは神様ですからね
先生がお前は仕事をしなさい
給料はご飯だけあげます
と言ったら はい わかりました
でやる世界でしょうに
どう常識で考えたって
もう先生はもう先輩でプロで
仕事に入ったばっかしでね
そんな給料もらわないでしょ
それで時間経ったところで
この人は自分も王様にもよく慣れたところで
自分の不安を言い出しちゃったんです
みんなの前で 宮殿で これは不公平ですと
私とこのグッテルさんと同じ給料で能力は同じでしょうし
同じ能力の同じ給料でしょうと
言うと グッティレ菩薩がものすごく恥ずかしくなって
やられたと なんとことかと
これ 弟子と師匠でしょ
だから初めから悪人に教えるなですよ
思っていたのに 向こうのお母さんのせいでどうだですよね
自分には大恥で その瞬間で
もう社会から逃げますと思ったんです
こんな社会にいることしか
それでまあ一応後でね
あの王様がね そんなことお前いい加減に言うなよと
能力ないじゃとか だったら先生と競争して勝ちなさいよ
みんなの前でそういう演奏会を用意してたんです
その場合は 先生とは競争しないのは普通でしょうに
まあ我々は先生と戦って勝ったりしますけど
それはまあもう家の中で勉強している時は
もうお互い様競争して
もうそれは勝たなくちゃいけないんですよ
先生に負けちゃうとものすごく先生にやられますからね
で もう勝ったところで先生はすごく喜んで
ああ まあよく学んでいるなとかね
ああ よかったよかったと
何かご褒美くれるだけで
外ではこれ殺されたってもやりません
これで公でやるんだからね
で 菩薩は何を考えていると
もうこんな世界ではいる必要はないんだと
自分はどうせ年やと あいつは若者やと
いくら私に能力あるとしたっても
筋肉の力では負けますよと
微妙にでもどんどん疲れてくると
これ何時間になるかわからないでしょうに
どんどん疲れてくると
年のボロが出るでしょうと
だから自分が一流のプロでいて
負けるっていうことはとんでもないけしからんなことやと
だから自殺するんだと
で 森に入って自殺することにしたんです
じゃあ自殺するちゃあれば
それで一般的な話なんですけど
仏教はそれで終わらないんです
意外なる菩薩は自殺しようと思うんだから
帝釈天が とんでもないことを
こんなままだったら 世の中は悪人だらけになるんだと
人格者の立場がなくなるんだよと
助けてあげなくちゃいけないんだと
この自殺首吊りしようとしているところに
何か人間の形に来て あんた何やっているのかと
自殺しようとも何かすごいことが起きたのでしたら
こういうことですよと言ったんですね
ああ 気にすることがね
あんた演奏会に出てくださいと
あのね そんなこと言ってもね
私は年だよと あれ すごい体力が必要だよと
相手が若者やと言ったら
私は誰か知ってますかと
私は帝釈天だけど あなたのこと心配して来たんだと
ですから あの適切にアドバイスしますからね
演奏会に出なさいというと
まあ決めて出ることになったんですが
その時は何かちょこっと
あのもう日本の物語で出てきますね
何か粒 3つくれたと それも持っていきなさいよと
それで演奏会が始めたら
もう演奏するわ するわするわ
ものすごい もうどちらかとわからなくて
みんなものすごい感心しながら喜んで聴いてるんですね
そこで人間の能力では
先生の能力も弟子の力もギリギリのところまで
今あらゆるからくりでやって
やってやっても どう見たっても平等
レベルが同じ それはなんでジャータカ物語でそこまで強烈に言うかというと
この菩薩は教える時 いかに立派に教えたかということなんです
嫌な人であっても だからもうどんどん夜になって
でもまだまだ勝敗決めてない
それで帝釈天が来ているんです
誰にも見えません どうせ神だから
で 菩薩には見える 帝釈天がもうこれではこれ以上はもううまくいかないんですね
それから神の手が入るんです
帝釈天がね あのね 弦一つ切りなさい
と菩薩に言うんです  行ったらあの何ですか
一番太い音を出すのは弦ですかね
それ切っちゃったんですね
まあどうせ負けちゃっても
この人自殺するつもりだからね
だからこれまあこれはちょっと神話的なとこが神話的に行くんですけどね
まあその場であの弦弾いたらどうでしょうかと考えた可能性もありますよ
これ切ったところで まだ買って聞いたことがない
美しい ものすごい音が出ているのです
もう何倍も声も音も良くなって
響きも良くなって 弦がないんだから
まあ弾くだけだから もっと楽でしょうしね
先生にはそう見たら あの人が
あら これは私に教えてくれなかった
この先生は隠しておいたと思って
あの馬鹿の弦を切っちゃったんです
切ったところでどんどん音が落ちたんです
それでもう負け まあそれからまあまた弦何本か切ったみたいんですけど
切ってもっと それからこの天国で天人たちが聴いてる音楽は流れるようになった
しかし 演奏はするんです
音だけは向こうからもう出してくれるんです
スピーカーでかな わからないんですけど
そうなってきたら もう負けは決まったし
でも喜んでみんな集めてるんだから
国中の人々はね みんなものすごい
なおさら喜びまして アビルソーという大将が
あの あんたもらったあの粒一つを上に出しなさいよと
それは信号なんですね
それ出した途端 天からいろんな天女たちがサーッと降りてきて踊り始めたんだと
それでまあグループ 3つ来てね
3回に分けて演奏に合わせて踊ってくれて
ブッダは勝ちましたけど
で あの人は追い出されたんだと
国からもう仕事として雇うべき人ではないんだと
道徳のある人に侮辱するならばということで
だからこの仏教の物語だから追い出されただけで終わらないんです
一応話は勝利まで行くんです
で そこで言いたかったのは
我々能力向上する場合は 3種類の能力が必要なんです
俗世間では 2種類なんです
しかし 性格というものはもっと大事ということなんです
それで経験を積むときは
性格を完成するという大きな枠の中で
技術 知識の経験を積むべきなのです
経験経験といっても 性格という大きな枠があります
その中でやるんです 経験というのは
性格という土台の上で積み重ねていくんです
築いていくんです だからベース
ファウンデーション 土台
基礎は性格なんです 逆に勉強できなくても
頭が悪くても 性格いい子は幸せになります
そういうのはもう世界的な事実なんです
能力 能力って言ってもね
能力より先に性格っていうことなんです
性格の良い人というのは
もう誰も勝てません これはよく覚えてほしいところで
次に性格を無視して知識技術を得る道は苦しいのです
失敗する可能性は大きいんです
今 我々は性格を無視して勉強したり
学んだりしているでしょ？習ったりとか
みんな勉強は難しいって言ってるでしょうに
競争は激しいとか 試験は難しいとか
先生は厳しいとか ストレス溜まるんだよとかね
頭がカチンカチンとなるそうとかね
なんででしょうかね それはおかしい
だって勉強すると脳が回転するでしょうに
医学的に見ても楽しくなるはずなんです
なんか興奮しちゃって
楽しくてやめられ やめられなくなるはずなんです
普段は正しく その性格の子なんかは
本を読んだり勉強したりすると
そればっかしやってて
お母さん逆に怒るんだよ
お前本ばっかし読むんじゃなくて
外に出てちょっと遊び遊んでこいとかね
本当の道だったら お母さんは勉強に邪魔するはずなんです
なぜかというと 勉強っていうのはものすごく刺激的で楽しくて
やみつきになるんです
でも実際の状況はどうですかというと
もうお母さんがずっとそばに見張っていないと勉強しない
道が間違っているんです
いわゆる性格は無視 うちの子は誰よりも勝てばいいやというね
いい大学に入ればいいんだと
それで私の立場がOKやという醜いトンチンキンなんですよ
自分個人ででも相手に勝ちたい
相手に負けたくないとか
そういう気持ち悪いことで勉強すると
勉強はものすごく難しいし
疲れるし ストレスが溜まるし
特に大学の研究とか大学院の研究なんかになってくると
ものすごく緊張しちゃうし
発表する時も発表する自信がなくなっちゃうし
大変なんです そういうわけで
性格は土台にして学ぶとものすごく楽しくなるので
何でも性格はできている人に他の経験を得ることはたやすいんです
性格が良ければ勉強する
いろんなものを習うということはすごく簡単なんです
性格が良い人はどうせ柔らかいでしょうね
筋肉も柔らかいし 頭も柔らかいし
だから新しいものを習ってみようかなと思ったら
もうすぐあ そういう風にやるんでしょうかと思って
すぐすぐすぐ上手になれるようになります
この世で難しいものはないが
性格の問題で心の問題で落第する人は多い
この世で難しいことはないんですよ
しかし 成功者は少ないでしょうね
例えば世界的なバイオリニストと言っちゃうと
もう何人かしかない 世界的でも
何よ これと  仕事でも勉強でも
ものすごいシンプルで簡単単純ですよ
しかし 落第するは落第するは落第する
どこでも それは心の問題
性格の問題なんです そこでもうこれでもう覚えたいところだ
もうこの世の中で もう難しいものなんかあり得とはしないんです
性格悪い人には何でも難しい
性格悪い人に勉強しろと言ったって難しいでしょうに
失敗するでしょうに それでモットーがありますよ
人は生涯学習ですということです
経験の世界 今説明してますからね
学べるものはない 行為
話 教え 娯楽 すべて無駄
無意味 虚しいということになるんです
いつでも我々は学ばなくてはならないんです
いつでも それから学ぼうと思っちゃうと
何でも学ぶことになるんですよ
学べる 教えてくれますよ
だから何が何かっていうことじゃないんですよ
もう何でもいいんです
例えばこの今ワイヤーとこういうコネクターといっぱいあるでしょうね
じゃあこれちょっと挿してちょうだいと言った途端
そのまま挿しちゃうと
これ微妙にでも壊れるでしょうね
じゃあこれ引いてと言った途端
コードで待って引いちゃうと
それ壊れるでしょうね
そういうところから それいちいち言う
だって分厚いマニュアルでしょうね
コードを引く場合は取るところあります
そちらから捕まって引いてください
バカバカらしい そんなこと言わなくたっての頭いるんだったらわかるでしょ
向きが間違わないようにとか
電気の機械の場合は だからもう私は私もいろいろ機械使ったり
コンピューター使ったりしますけど
わからないところはありますけど
あれヘルプあれで見ると何の役にも立たない
あのくっだらんことばっかり書いてるんだから
コンピューターは例えば何かうまくいかない場合はヘルプで見たらまず電源入れてくださいと
まず いいアドバイスです
で まあそんな程度なんですよ
それもあの昨日もあの USB ポートの一つは認識できないと言って
うるさい 認識できないから黙っていればいいでしょうね
これも出るんだから まあいいや
動かしてみるぞと そしたらまあこのこのこのセクションが認識できないんだと
で まあ知ってるんだから
私はもう別にどうやって動かすのかと
まあせっかく言ってくれるんだからね
これでトラブルシューティングを押したところで
何やこれと で これでこの役に立ちましたか？とまた聞くんだからね
それでまあ人に馬鹿にするのはいい加減にしなさいと
それはもう消しちゃって
まあ別にまあ 別なことで
まあ私はプログラム あの
あのセクションのをね
もう認識しないことにしたんです
認識しないことにしたんですけど
電気がついてますから
コンピューターから見れば USB 機器とつなげているんですけど
読めないんだよという話ですよ
ね 私は読むなよと言ってるんだからね
まあとにかくあの人は生涯学習なんです
仏道もそうなんです 完全悟を開くまで有学なんです
人間はみんなこの生まれてから無学の状態で気分よくいること
無学っていうのは悟った人のことなんです
で ですから 何でも我々に何か教えてくれる
何でもいいんです 何か教えてくれる
そういうことで 学ぶもの
学べるものがなければはっきりと無駄
無意味 人生台無しになる
大事な時間が ダメになっちゃうんです
だからゲームやってもいいんだけど
そこから何か学んでほしいんです
学ぶこと 経験を得ることを楽しみにしなくてはならないんです
これが我々の楽しみなんですよ
学ぶこと だから学ぶということはというと
幅広い意味なんです 知識だけじゃないんです
経験することも いろんなものを見て理解することも
人の話を聞くことも ただ
私は人と喋っている場合は
くっだらない無意味な無駄話ばっかりやっていると内容は聞きません
別なことを聞いているんです
何か勉強になるものはないのかと
そうすると発見しますよ
頭が悪い人はかなり声がでかいんだぞとかね
他人に喋らせないんだよとかね
じゃあ他人に喋らせないで
自分だけ勝手にとんとんしゃべる人もいる
意見聞いたら喋る人もいる
私それ見て意見聞いたら喋る人が要点だけ言ってまた黙るんですね
聞いてもないのに喋る人はもうもう止まりなさいと言ったって止めてくれないし
言ってることは全部ゴミで何の役にも立たないし
私はそういうことでは勉強です
だってあの話を聞いちゃうと大変なことになるんだから
話は無駄話 しかし 見方によって別なものは勉強になる
まあ私にしてみれば 何でも勉強になるんです
勉強になるもの何一つもないんです
しかし 煩悩を増やす学び方は不善行為です
だから まあ例えば若い人々もいますけどね
だったらよくモテるように
何か何を学べるかといって学んじゃうとモテるかもしれませんだけど
まあそれはやっぱり欲を増やす世界だから
それはあんまり仏教が推薦する善行為ではありません
推薦するのは人格を完成する学び方なんです
全然モテない若い男たちが私に相談するときでも教えてあげますけど
どうすれば女にモてますかと
しかし それは仏教が推薦する道ではありません
仏教が推薦するのは 人格を完成する方向へ学んで学んでいってくださいと
例えば野生の猫でもね
まあ餌見つけてそれに喧嘩すると
それが何か学べるでしょうに
こちらも食べたい あちらも食べたい
そこで力ある人は奪っちゃうというね
ああ 生きるということはこういうことやと
で 学べばいいでしょうね
それで経験を得るということは見習いということなんですよ
経験と知識がなければ仕事がないという状況もあります
それで経験必要必要で今喋ってますけど
何もできない人はどうやって経験得るんですかね
仕事を出してくれないんですよね
我々に経験を得たくても
その場がない 与えてくれないということもあります
経験はしたいんだけど
場がないと 例えばもうじゃあ外科で考えましょう
外科の卵の先生がいて
もう手術したいんです
手術しなかったら経験 0 だから認めませんだからね
誰も与えてくれません
自分の先生も 先生のところに手術を受ける患者が来たら
じゃあ君切ってくださいと
ものは試しだからと 冗談じゃないでしょうね
結局は熟練者がやってしまいますよ
特に医学の場合は 手術の数が多ければ多いほど医者がいいんです
それはどういうことでしょうかね
しかし 何事でも真剣に正しく行うものです
半端でいい加減で良いということはないんです
で 次に行きます しかし
見習いの精神でいるならば
その場を得られるんです
それで解決なんです 例えば外科の若いインターンの先生は
自分が見習いであると
大胆なことするものではないんだと
自分の仕事は一生懸命先生について頼むことをしてあげることやと
そうすると先生は順番で君
これやってください これやってくださいと下の仕事からどんどんどんどんやらせるんですよ
お腹は切らしたりさせませんだけど
自分が手術終わったところで
はい では最初の手術しなさいとかね
いわゆる最後に締めるところとかね
それですごいすごくいい仕事をくれた先生と
ものすごい真剣にそれやってくれると
それで一つできたっていうことですね
それ何回 何回もやっていくと
この人はすごい真剣だ
真面目だ では今度はお腹を開けるところのことを頼みましょうということになるんです
それででは君開けてくださいと
そうすると その人はそこを開ける
その時でもいちいち言うんですね
手はこういう風に取るんだ
これはこれやあれやこれやこうとかね
それなら先生は本当の手術に手を出して
それからじゃあ最後の処理しなさいと
そういうやり方で見習い
見習い 一生一生見習いでいると
いくらでも経験は得られるんですよ
これ 悪いこといきなり自分ができそうな顔をするんですよ
会社に入って 1週間で文句を言うんだから
だから私は出勤して本当に良かったと思ってますよ
いろんな人の話を聞くと
あれあれ もし私が会社経営したら
この人を雇ったらどうなるのかと
私ならもう 1時間以内でクビにするなのにとかね
これ犠牲事業じゃない
何ですか？犠牲事業じゃないんで
これは儲かる世界だと何人かにははっきり言ったこともあります
私ならあなたは最初から雇いませんよ
ある面で人は成長しなくちゃいけないし
仕事をする場を与えなくちゃいけないし
経験得る場を与えなくちゃいけないんですよ
私たちは後輩を育てなくちゃいけないんですよ
でも こいつは生まれてからの先生だったらどうしますかね
生まれるともう先生なんです
こちらが教えをしているのです
これで話は終わりと まあ私に教えてもらう子供は
あのね これはこれでこれでやります
言っちゃうと聞いてあげますけど
まあ子供と一生懸命教えてあげようと思っちゃいますからね
それは別に子供でっかい態度をとっているわけじゃなくて
自分が知ったことを もう自分がいろいろ工夫して学んだことをね
もう誰か聞いてくれる人にもう言いたいだけのことでね
我々には毎日経験を積み重ねて
立派に一人前にはなれませんよ
一人前にはなりません
半人前でいいんです 見習いでいいんだよ
人生はいつでも見習いの精神で真剣勝負
真面目に便所掃除頼んだら
それは完璧にやってほしい
だから仏教の影響だから
私たちはいつでもテスト出しますよ
テストは一番シンプルなところで出します
そこで見事に失敗するんだだからそれからは無視
無関心 だから大胆な仕事を頼んで
そこで見て大胆に仕事を頼んだら失敗するのは決まってるんだから
それに怒りもしません
何もないんです 責任任せたところでいろいろ失敗やったら
これは当たり前だからね
そういうところでテストしません
いろんな 本当にシンプルで
全く気づかないところで
この間 自分の親戚のね
いとこの孫みたい 孫よりも小さい年
もう3代ぐらいの親戚の子がね
まあ向こうの家族がね
なんとかお寺に出したいというかね
まあもう私の金を狙ってるかどうかがわかりませんだけど
まあどうでもいいんだからね
子供でしょうしね 育ててあげて悪くはないし
だからまあ来るならばとことん育ててやろうとは思ってるんです
しかし テストがあります
私の場合 本人はやるつもりでいるかっていうことなんです
5歳ですけど  5歳か６歳あたりです
だから小さすぎかもしれません
でもそれでも見えますよ
自分で判断して行動する子供かって
そこをテスト出したところでもう大失敗で
それでも親戚だからちょっとチャンス与えて
まあ緊張したでしょうとかね
もうちょっとお寺に来て
学校を休む時はね まあ様子見なさいとチャンス与えたんです
これ普段はあげません
親戚だから そこはまあ特別にチャンス
そこで私はこちらから電話して
お寺の面倒を見る人に
もしあの子はお寺で止めてもいい
泊まりまあ言うならば泊まってやるそうと言ったならば
すぐ学校に話して 向こうは学校にいるのはものすごい難しいんです
だから まあ自分住んでいる場所
通っている学校以外なかなか大変です
だからお寺になってくると場所も違いますからね
それでも学校の話あって
まあお寺のこういうことだったら
まあなんとか入れてあげますよ
そちらも話はつけてます
聞いてます かなり厳しいという状況で
お寺の全部言っているんですけど
本人にだけ言ってないんです
その本人の親にもそんな話は全然していない
電話もかけも何もしません
そこで最後の日にちになってくると
また私は電話をかけて
あの子は今何言ってるんでしょうかと
家に帰りたいと言って思ってる
言ってるんだよ ああそう
それで私は終わり そこで家に連れて行って
後で他の人に電話かけて
そうですね あれこれでもなんでお前連れてあなた方は連れて行ったんですか？で
時期が来て連れて行ったみたいですね
いえ 先生から何も話がなかったんだから
あの学校始まりますから連れて行った
ああ そうですか はっきり言った
あのね 私はあなた方みんなにまとめてテスト出しましたからね
見事に失敗だから話は終わりですと
それで話終わったんです
終わったんだから言ったのは
そういうあなた方らのだらしない思考でね
人は成長しませんよと
本人が子供だから 学校なんか気にするもんじゃないでしょうに
で あの環境に雰囲気が気に入られて
あるいは挑戦的 私は挑戦的な気分になったんだからね
これはえらい挑戦だと思って
でお寺に入ったんですから
その子ももし挑戦的な気分になって
では止めてやろうではないかとか思ったらね
学校はそれを気にしない
それだったらOKなんです
決まったことをやる子だから
それが大人の責任でしょうに
教育させるのは それだったらもう一流の教育をさせるし
私は でもテストはまあそれで落第
まあそういうことを何かというと
我々は人生の中でもこの見習い精神でいないんですよ
見習い精神でいると何でも挑戦なんですよ
自分を試してるんですよ
できることならやってみろと言われているんですよ
だからそちらで挑戦していかなくちゃいけないんです
それで見習いでいつ一人前になるかというと
一人前になりません  皆さんも何人か知ってると思いますけど
御旗さんというね あの飛行 ＪＡＬ
のね まあパイロットのね
まあトップクラスの人なんですけど
だからもうずっとやってることだから
自分も他の人々にも教えたり指導したりもするし
でもフライトがあるたびに
前の日にずっとそこらシミュレーションして考えて
あれこれで一生懸命学んでから行くんだって
毎回毎回 ルートやら何でも
だからまるっきり目を閉じていてもできるようにぐらい
この訓練はいつでもいつでも受けるんだと
だからまあ 本当の世界はそういう世界でしょうに
だから一人前にはなりません
一人前っていうのは悟ったらもう一人前
そこまで見習い まあその精神があったら
もう経験というのはいくらでも得られます
注意 知ったつもり できるつもりは危険
間違いはいつでも起こり得るんだからね
無責任な無神経な人はよく自慢していろいろやるが
失敗して皆に迷惑をかける
丁寧に地道に真剣に仕事をする人ではないと
見習いとしても失格です
言い訳を与える人 考える人は初めからの見込みがないんです
こういうことだからこうなったんだよと
言うんだったら もう見込みはないんです
はい 早く終わりにしましょう
そこでやっとジャータカ物語に入りますけど
ジャータカ物語言いません
このジャータカ物語というのはどういうものかと
様々な問題に対して 仏教の立場
見方 解決方法を示す物語なんですよ
ただの仏教は無駄話しませんだからね
みんなに何かエピソード
物語で楽しませてやるぞとかね
そんなのはないんです
わかりやすく教えてやるぞと
だからジャータカ物語を言うんです
それでジャータカ物語の中にある哲学がありますよ
世の中にある様々な問題について
仏教ならどう見るのかと
仏教の見方は何なのかと
仏教の解決策は何なのかということを教えているんです
ユーモアに溢れているストーリーですが
娯楽的な目的はありません
ジャータカ物語は結構ユーモアありますよ
今 私 皆様に紹介したあれにでも
あの虫にあれ食われているんだよとかね
すごくからかってるでしょうに
あの人の能力を それから商人たちがあんたはこれ楽器の調整でしょうと
だからもうものすごくいっぱいは入ってますよ
しかし 笑わせて気分を良くする道はないんです
何か教えるんです 現代的な小説のようにキャラクターを使用して進むストーリーもあるが
人生観として何かを読者に学ばせる目的なんです
まあ本当に小説のようなストーリーもありますよ
見事に各キャラクターのいろいろ特色を与えてあげて
そこで発展していって
最終のところまで持っていくんです
しかし 小説じゃないんです
何か教えてやるんです
菩薩は常に学ぶべきキャラクターです
だからどんなジャータカにも菩薩はいるんです
なぜ一つの菩薩のキャラクターにするかというと
まあそこは仏教の代表ですね
で 菩薩っていうのは見習いという意味なんです
大乗仏教はどこを勘違いしたかわかりませんだけどね
ブッダより菩薩は偉いんだと
誰が教えてあげたかわかりませんだけど
ボーディサットワっていうのはもう見習いという意味なんです
出家に対する戒めより
在家生活に関わる戒めのストーリーが多いんです
このジャータカの特色なんですよ
経典を読んでみると ほとんど出家に出家に
出家に出家に語っていますよ
それでジャータカ物語を読んでみると
もうたまたま出家は出ますけど
まあほとんど在家の世界なんです
仏教の道徳観倫理は厳しい
曖昧ではありません 不殺生と言えば
いかなる場合でも殺してはならないという話です
嘘をつくなよと言ったら
ニコニコと冗談ででも嘘をついてはならないんです
ダメなものはダメ 微塵でも
という話 仏教はね しかし
実際の生活ではそう簡単にはいかないケースもあるでしょうに
嘘は全く絶対言わないと言ったっても
ああ ちょっと困ったなということは実際生活では起こるんですよ
倫理観を壊さず 道徳項目の何ですか
微調整しているのはジャータカです
そこで あ この場合はちょこちょこっとこんな風にした方がいいんじゃないかなという
この道徳は守ってるんで壊せません
いかなる場合でも殺していいとは言わないんだけど
やっぱりジャータカでは殺す物語もあります
相手が殺してしまったということはあります
しかし 不殺生はちゃんと道徳はある
守っているんです だからかなりの役ですよ
ジャータカ物語の場合
そこで実際私たちは殺生しませんとかね
嘘をつきませんとかね
盗みはしませんとか言ってはいいんだけど
これはこの完璧に 何て言いますかね
数学的に守るないんですよ
もう人間生活っていうのはすごくファジーでしょうし
もうデジタルじゃないんだからね
ほとんど曖昧でしょうし
その中で この実践の世界ではどのように自分が泳ぐのかというジャータカ物語は教えてくれます
在家仏教徒の生き方として理解してもよろしい
ジャータカ物語っていうのは
在家仏教徒の生き方であると
そこでまあ余計な話で
もうジャータカの物語
本当にブッダの過去生でしょうかと
まあ正直なところよくわかりません
私も テーラワーダ仏教は釈尊に説かれたブッダ自身の過去生菩薩の物語として認めているんです
倫理を語るために作った話
また借りた話もないとは現代的な立場で言えないわけではありませんと
かなりないの言葉たくさんありますけど
私も何言ってるかわかりません
それは私の個人的な考えですから
私はまあ まさか借りたストーリーもないのかとかね
わざわざと作ったストーリーもないのかとかね
そういう気持ちもあります
しかし 王政のストーリー
結構成り立ってますからね
それはまあ 私はそういうところを研究する気持ちはないし
だからまあ言いたい気持ちもないんです
しかし ジャータカの芸はパーリ経典の中でもとても古い文語体なんです
しかし バカにすることはできないんですよ
ジャータカという芸があるんですよ
それが我々が勉強するパーリ語の経典があるでしょ
あの言語よりも古いんです
だから仏典の中で一番古いセクションに入るんです
現世の因縁エピソードと過去世の物語は注釈書にあるから
経典ではありません ですから
ジャータカ物語ははっきりと書いているのは注釈書なんですよ
だからそれにちょこちょことケチつけちゃっても大丈夫です
経典じゃないんです これはちょっとおかしいとかね
言ったってもあまり罰が当たりません
しかし 道徳はちゃんとありますからね
そこをね ケチつけてはいけません
しかし 経典の中でもジャータカがあります
しかし そう簡単でもないんです
経典の中でお釈迦様がジャータカ説かれた時もありますからね
注釈書だからまあケチつけてやろうと思っても
やっぱりどこかで気をつけないと
お釈迦様自身でジャータカ物語を語ったことというのは結構ありますからね
パーラミタ パラミタですと
様々な修行方法に関わる話は本当にブッダの過去世でしょう
そこでジャータカ物語は550いくつかありますよ
553か4ぐらいかな
ありますけど その中でちゃんと10パラミットあります
パーリミタ それ このジャータカでこのパーラミタ
このジャータカでこのパーラミタである場合は
もうそれはもう仏教の一般的なもう作り話でも何でもない
ブッダ菩薩の過去世物語なんですね 10
パラミッタに分けにくいが
俗世間的な戒めになるエピソードの中で作ったものもあり得る
このエピソードでどんなパーラミタでしょうかと聞いてわからない場合もありますよ
その場合はもしかすると何か教えたくてエピソードを作った可能性もあります
本当のことでも 語り続くと派手に変わることも自然です
それから物語っていうのは
この語り続く いわゆる伝言ですね
ナレーションですね そうなってくると
ナレーターが語る人がちょっと調整するんですよ
私もジャータカ物語を語る場合は
テキスト通りには言いません
いろいろ調整して編集するんです
その場で その場で 相手が子供なら
何かもうちょこっと面白いセクションを挿すんですよ
そういうことだから 物語を語る場合は
どうしても何か調整が入ります
そういうわけで 奇跡が入ったり
もう摩訶不思議なこと入ったり
もっと派手になったりというふうなことは
いわゆる変化は起こり得ますよ
この物語の世界では だから現代
我々のもう腐りかけている知識で
認めがたい  ちょっとおかしいと思うものはどうしようもないんです
そんなのは どんな文化でも物語文化はそうなるんです
日本にしても 桃太郎の何太郎なんかあるでしょうに
鬼退治に行ったとかね
そうなりますよ もともとは何かあったでしょうね
ちょっとした出来事 ほんのちっぽけな出来事があったと思いますよ
それでジャータカの全体的教訓は覚えておきましょう
恵み ついてる ラッキーなどはありません
人は地道に努力して成長するべきです
正しく理性に基づいて努力すれば不可能はありませんが
何でもできる人になる必要もなしと
ジャータカの全体的な５５０のジャータカは
そういうことを我々に教えているんです
不可能はないんだけど
だからといって何でもやる必要もないんだよ
それから恵みはありません
全部経験を積み重ねて積み重ねて
自分で能力向上することで得るんです
学べるものはない 行為
教えや努力は無意味無駄ということ
大事なのは一時的な能力
成功より人格向上ということ
だからジャータカ物語で王様は敵を抑えてもう国を治めて大成功しよう
終わりません ジャータカは
それで彼が法に従って道徳を守って
国民に幸せを与えて 自分の死後を天国に行くことにしましたということで終わるんです
だから人格向上は一番大事なことなんです
怠けたり 人がやってるだろうと思ったり
いわゆる私がやらなくて誰かやってくれるでしょうとか思ったりとかね
自分がダメなのは他人のせいだと思ったりするのは正しくないと
まあ私は掃除は誰が掃除するでしょうとかね
それは仏教的な生き方じゃないんです
仏教でいうのは ゴミが見た人が掃除するんだよと
掃除当番誰でしょうかっていうのは私にも言われたことなんですけど
まあ怠け者だからとにかく逃げちゃいます
もういろいろ隠れ遊んだりする長老たちが
まあもう子供だからあまり気にしないでもう掃除
掃除とかしますけど で
私がそばで長老が掃除始めたらそこら辺でまた遊び出すんですね
そうすると まあゴミっていうのは見た人が掃除するもんでしょうとか
なんとか言うんですね
私は聞いてないふりをしながらやっぱり聞いてはいるんです
聞いて覚えてもおくんです
不幸になるのは神の試練ではなく
自分の行為の結果ですが
そこからも知恵のある人は何かを学んで不幸を生かして得をするんです
まあ人は不幸なこれ 神の試練ですとかね
なんて暗い話でしょうかね
なんで神がある人を選んでひどい目に遭わせて試練にするんですかね
相当病気ですね 神も よくそういうことを信じること
人間が ヘリックスを僕ではあなた不幸なの
あなたの行為の結果だよと
だからといっていちいち泣くなよと
この不幸から何か学べる得するものがあるんだよ
そういうのをジャータカ物語で教えているんです
理性と知恵は 生きる上ではすべてに勝る力なのです
いっぱい このこの最後のライン
あの知恵のジャータカがいっぱいあるんですよ
頭がすごく使って 何かを見事に解決しているジャータカというのは結構あります
知恵のジャータカ だからこのジャータカはいつでも知恵というものをすごく賛嘆
賛嘆しています で なんとか終わりそう
あ 終わってるんです で
終わってはいるんですけど
ジャータカ物語からこのいろいろ紹介はしてないんですね
一番いいのは じゃあちょこっと休憩にして
ジャータカについてもうちょこっと喋ってみましょう